before we get into the new business that
you've developed you mentioned briefly
that you say you come from a land of
blocked writers yeah hear about that yes
I come from the tribe of blocked writers
I've spent I at the age of three I knew
I was meant to write and I've spent a
long time learning how to write and
would always meet this walk where I
couldn't finish things and I couldn't
bring things to completion I would write
brilliant first acts and have visions of
the the end but couldn't get the whole
thing to work together so I developed a
process to break through that and
basically get people out of their head
and into their genius and it's the whole
idea of really understanding that if you
really want to write that internal guide
will take you but you have to stop
thinking so that the guide takes over
and it's it's a process of finding of
letting go of perfection letting go of
needing to know and exploring random
acts of genius by just taking whatever
comes to you and believing that the idea
that you have is enough to go forward
isn't that something that makes a writer
a writer is the person that just is
overthinking everything over analyzing
like this analysis paralysis a lot of
people go through yeah and there's and
especially when you're writing for a
living
or writing because you want to create a
living there there tends to have a place
where writers thinking that they need to
meet the marketplace I need to write
something that'll sell I need to write
something that that will be great and
and if you think about it the way the
way artistry works the way writing
really works is that you're the conduit
and you're the toolbox and if you can
trust that what you have and what you
know is enough to finish the story
and you allow like like having a tool
box so there's a tool box for suspense
there's a tool box for for creating love
there's a tool box for creating a big
finish or creating that page-turner
there's there's actual tools for that so
you can learn the tools but the story
itself is part of you and and the
moments are part of you and the big
thing is realizing that stories in
general are not plot we think they're
plot but they're not their emotions
their their moments that generate
emotion so if you become more concerned
with the things inside you that feel
like they're emotional and you get those
emotions on the page or in a scene then
you can find ways to create the internal
logic of a story to bring them together
so so it's just shifting from plot into
emotion really going back to when you
were three yeah I want to hear about
what it was that where you knew that you
were meant to be a writer what was it
you were doing at three that's fast
thing my mother was northen and she had
a photographic memory and she would work
out these stories of her orphanage
experience and I really believed that
that we were all meant to just remember
everything and to tell these stories to
other people and so I would remember
like I would go back and remember what
was I doing a year ago in school what
was i doing a week ago in school or who
has said to me at what time you know
what was I what was I saying or doing
and I and I started sort of telling
myself my own story and thinking in the
future I will tell people these stories
that I'm thinking myself as a child and
then I loved I loved reading and I loved
imagining other worlds and and putting
myself in other worlds and so that was
just always and then I became a
storyteller I became fascinated by why
stories affect us why am i in terms of
endearment and I'm just weeping what how
how is it that something I'm seeing from
people I don't know is making me cry and
and so I just became really fascinated
at that at the mechanics of creating
motion and creating motion and stories
so when you say overthinking and sort of
it is it almost like it has its roots in
meditation where you're turning off the
mind in some sense you are and so this
process that I've developed because
because you need guideposts right and
it's kind of the way I think about it is
like this if you're telling a story you
need to know the genre you need to know
what you want to create what feeling you
want to generate and that genre that
destination is like saying I want to go
to Phoenix right that's your guideposts
I'm going to Phoenix I'm telling a love
story
now how you get to Phoenix could have a
number of different ways and so what you
have to think about is well along this
route where do I want to stop where are
my scenes
well maybe Palm Springs maybe Joshua
Tree you maybe want to take a big detour
down to Baja
right you can do that but you know
you're getting to Phoenix and so so the
way I think about story is to give you
those guideposts of the act structure
the end of the end of the first act the
midpoint end of the second act the
climax so those your guideposts like
saying I'm gonna hit Palm Springs and
Joshua Tree and Baja and then and and
you can create the visuals you can
create the that the you can create the
scenes around those places because you
know you got to get there but once you
know those guideposts you know there's a
journey to those places and you can
relax in knowing that the that the
journey has an organic flow and you
don't have to force it and you can relax
and let your your meditative mind take
over how you get there because you know
you're gonna stop in Palm Springs and
have a wonderful experience you know
you're gonna stop in Joshua Tree and
have a wonderful experience and then you
ultimately you'll get to Phoenix which
is your climax
and you you can imagine what's going to
happen there so it's it's kind of
releasing your mind from needing to know
how you get there and instead just
imagining wonderful destinations along
the journey I don't know if that's clear
at all but I try to think of another way
to say it you when you when you're when
you're looking to tell a story there's
an emotion that you want to create
there's two skills to learn one is the
actual that the means of generating
emotion whether it's generating how
somebody's gonna cry in a love story or
how to create suspense in a thriller and
then there's the story you want to tell
and that story can be very organic it
can be really who you are and the tools
of genre and the tools of these the
storytelling allow you to take the
internal you and make it into something
that an audience will want to see but
you don't have to control it to get
there it you can you can do it in a more
organic way in terms of getting people
out of their heads
do you have other exercises that are
maybe even physical in nature because I
think a lot of people myself included
like sometimes I have trouble falling
asleep and it just like this this
repetitive thoughts that are in my brain
and I think a lot of people that you
know overthink things are like that are
there exercises to get people out of
that because sometimes you have to
really literally get yourself out of a
physical place and go somewhere else
yes um first you should appreciate the
value of daydreaming daydreaming without
a purpose is an imagining Otherworld
actually does scientifically stimulate
your brain and relax you
physical exercise always important
taking a walk around the building
getting your body moving getting your
endorphins moving some people actually
need really heavy endorphin push to get
out of that hamster brain and into into
a meditative space for a lot of people
meditation is really hard because
you let your worried mind take over so
finding a simple exercise like watch
literally saying to your breath it's
yourself in in in breath out out out
breath and and and allowing just your
own voice of in in in out out out can
calm you down but the other thing is
belief when you believe that you have to
get somewhere or you have to achieve
something it's much harder to get there
if you believe that who you are right
now what you're writing right now is
actually destined to come in the world
and you can just relax and let it come
and the thing that you're going to write
next is the perfect sentence and the
next word is the perfect sentence and
even if you're just writing I don't know
what I'm writing I don't know what I'm
writing I'm waiting for something
inspiring to come to me I'll just wait
and keep typing and then you start
enjoying the feeling of typing start
enjoying the feeling of your fingers
start enjoying a great word pick a
surprising word and I promise you
eventually if you just keep typing that
next idea will come and the next idea
will come and if you don't judge it you
allow the next thing to come there will
be a progression that will take you
forward being a writer actually requires
a number of different skills and when
you're not good at one of the skills it
can make you think you're not good at
any of them and that is one of the
reasons that hamster brain occurs so one
thing is simply the use of language if
English is not your first language or
you tend to write awkwardly sometimes
you think you're not a good writer
because your word choice is bad but
that's one skill that you can work on
like literally like a dictionary skill
like choosing great vocabulary and
choosing great imagery
that's one skill second skill is taking
a character through a journey it's
actually understanding the psychology of
people and understanding if I'm I think
I'm ugly how do I walk through the world
how does a character overcome the belief
that I'm ugly right and that's actually
an understanding of people and
understanding of psychology and you want
to let know that so you can create
characters that are deep and interesting
and you want to be a great observer of
your friends of your parents of your of
all the people who annoy you right so
that you can document the document who
they are but also understand them from
an interesting perspective that's a
different skill then there's another
skill which is especially for filmmaking
is being able to show not tell being
able to ground all of your scenes in
moments that are visual that extent that
give all the information you want to
give but don't don't have it let me tell
you and then this happened and then this
happened and then this happened and then
this happened right and the last one
which is probably the most important one
and very difficult for people to do is
to really speak from your authentic
voice and we we we want so much as
writers to be seen and to be heard and
we know that we have something to say
and that desire that longing can pull us
out of ourselves and and when you get
pulled out of yourself then you're
trying to imitate Breaking Bad you're
trying to imitate scandal you're trying
to imitate some movie that you love and
you've lost your sense of what it is
you're bringing to the world what you've
seen in the world so finding that
authentic voice and saying what I know
is valuable what I see is valuable the
way I'm going to show it is valuable
is a skill in itself and it's the
practice of actually affirming your
unique vision like being able to go into
a Starbucks even and saying the way I
order my Starbucks the way I like my
Maya pasta the way I like to cross the
street the way I like to drive is unique
and valuable and the more you anchor
into the sense of your own value and the
importance of your voice in the world
the more powerful that voice is going to
be because the other things I describe
are literally like techniques that you
can practice but this other technique of
actually affirming your own authentic
voice is probably the most important one
so how can someone know whether they've
gotten lost in other voices and are
trying to emulate another show another
writer because maybe they think oh yeah
this is me too but really they're
copying True Blood or they're they're
you know it's it's almost like the the
girl in high school who wants to be like
the popular girl yes and so she starts
dressing like her and trying to do her
hair like her but really she's not being
who she really needs to be she's trying
to be somebody who seems popular and
wanted when you know we all want to be
successful and one of the ways we we
find success is to look at other people
and say oh I can pick I can I like the
way she looks so I'm gonna look like her
I like the way he writes so I'm going to
write like her and you hear all these
stories of like even Joan Didion who
copied Ernest Hemingway in order to find
her voice but what you want to do but
you know you're on the wrong track if
you if you start feeling that anxiety
that I could never be like her that I'm
oh when I compare myself to his writing
I'm just really not I and you start
feeling that that sense of not good
enough not meeting something and you
start wanting to be seen you can feel
that pull of wanting to be seen like
your Idol
and and that's the moment where you know
if you were talking about a physical
look you'd go get plastic surgery right
so I could put her nose on my face
so I can put his words in my script or
my story and so when you start feeling
that you have to recognize that you're
walking away from yourself you're
walking away from yourself and trying to
sit in somebody else's image and if you
do that you will always be a shadow of
someone else the truth of who you are
the reason that you came to write won't
come out
it won't flourish it's kind of like
you'll you'll be that that that plant
that just doesn't get enough water and
doesn't get enough Sun so it might bloom
but the flower will be small and the
fruit will be bitter right and if you're
really gonna anchor in yourself you have
to believe that you are as brilliant as
as the person you want to be and so
you're going to appreciate how they
shine but you're not going to copy how
they shine you want to appreciate how
strong they are in their voice and you
want to practice your own voice as
loudly as you can
now the awkward thing is you're going to
practice that voice and it's not going
to be good right we're never good when
we start playing the piano we're never
great when we start driving we crash
into things right if it takes practice
but you have to hang on to the belief so
this is the disconnect you have to know
that even though you may not look good
at what you're doing yet what you're
doing is not accomplishing the vision of
what you want to accomplish ultimately
you have to believe that you're gonna
get there just as you are
so it's hanging on to the tension of
being not so good an amateur awkward but
believing that you're gonna grow into
something that will flourish and bloom
and you're gonna have to have patience
and that's the most difficult thing
because when you're when you're
struggling and you want success and you
know you're good
but it's not coming there's a tendency
to say what I'm on the wrong path the
universe doesn't want me to do this I
should go to that path I should follow
that path anchor in this is where
meditation becomes really important and
really knowing that there's a there are
stories inside of you that need to be
told just the way you want to tell them
and having the patience to wait for them
to bloom so that the the timing is right
and that your timing is right as an
artist and that timing is right in the
marketplace I heard an interview with a
writer I'm not sure if it was Judy Blume
the other day - it was someone on that
level and and they said that they try
not to read other writers while they're
writing a book because then their voice
becomes like their favorite writers and
and so do you often see that though for
people are really copying other people
and they don't even realize it they just
know I love that and so this is how I
want it to sound you know we we
definitely live in a culture especially
in the screenwriting world where you're
supposed to read as many scripts as you
can to learn how to write write read
read read read read but I believe
strongly in bubbles I believe you should
put em big magic thick plexi silent
bubble around you when you write so they
and and and the other thing you put in
your bubble is everything that you love
if you love you know bubblegum and
butterflies and unicorns or if you love
you know you know 60s music or whatever
it is you have to surround yourself with
the essence of you and-and-and and be
careful of criticism I'm a strong
believer in not allowing any of the baby
the babies that you're writing to ever
see the light of day I've seen so many
babies who've just been born as little
scripts be told that they will never get
go to college and never grow up to be
beautiful because someone didn't get
them and you think about projects now
like
transcendence and me sorry it's makeup
projects like transparent and quirky
stories orange is the new black or where
they're deeply personal and they would
never show they'll be they never live if
the wrong person saw that story and so
be careful and be careful of allowing
criticism be careful of allowing other
voices surround yourself with the bubble
that is authentically you so you feel
yourself you taste yourself you smell
yourself and you love that bubble and
what comes out of that will be so much
more unique and in this world of
storytelling uniqueness authenticity
originality is what it breaks through
and so that's what you want you want to
take a big bath and you defining who
someone is what if someone's not sure
what they really you know I remember
like you'd make these boards where you'd
cut out from magazines things that you
like and things that are similar to you
is it almost something like that where
you you know I think we know more of who
we are when we're 7 than we do when
we're 27 and and it's you know we we
live in a world of Facebook and Twitter
and an Instagram where we're constantly
bombarded with other people's
experiences and other people's view of
the world and and I think we need to be
as artists be much more protective of
what we what we allow in because of the
because of envy envy and the desire to
live other people's lives and that
competitive sense that maybe they're
doing more than I am or not enough or
I'm somehow not living the life I should
live makes it dilutes your sense of
yourself and it also reminds you you
need to go say oh wow Tahiti I'd love to
go to Tahiti I'll put that on my bucket
list
but I believe in a lot of practices of
list making and one of the lists that I
always make there's a list of a hundred
of things to do be in half and in that
list of a hundred and it can be simple
things like I want to have a star I want
to have coffee at the end of the Santa
Monica Pier on a sunset with my
boyfriend right
but that list you'll begin to see what
you think is happiness what you want to
bring into your life it's really unique
and it's not like anybody else's and
conglomerate and and when things those
things start manifesting because I also
believe that when you write it down it
comes you see more of yourself in your
life and so as a writer as an art
especially since so much of us so many
of us are introverts we live in our
heads and when you start making
declarations to the universe this is
what I want to do be and have in my life
you naturally go look for those things
to do be in half because you get excited
by them but the universe also starts
delivering them which creates more
authenticity in yourself because you
become more yourself because you're
getting more of what you want to do be
in half so this this collection of
experiences reinforces that voice and
your attention to yourself and your
desire to be yourself will also collect
more energy into your authenticity so
tell me about this list a little more so
it's it's I'm sorry hundred things
hundred things I challenge all of you
yeah to make a list okay I have a
hundred because it's when you a hundred
is a lot it is yeah and it's a hundred
things to do be and have and they can be
grand and small so it can be I I want a
Cartier tank watch right that's to have
I want to ride an elephant in India
that's due to be I want to be a big
sister to somebody I want to be the
person who everyone turns to at a
Halloween party right
so we it's it's imagining all the things
that would really make you happy and
what's interesting about this exercise
is you realize how little we think about
what really makes us happy on the most
micro levels so you think about okay I
want to have you when you start reading
it changes it changes your perspective
of how you interact with the world when
you have this hundred list because now
when you read the LA Magazine's top ten
restaurant lists oh well there's ten
restaurants I got to put that on my list
I want to eat the octopus at ilku Genie
I want to taste the sushi at you know
fancy sushi place so you this collection
and begins to you begin to see your
inner world in an external place and
that helps you see yourself do we show
this list to others or is this a
personal list that we just keep to
ourselves it's it's best to keep it
personal I'm a big believer in not
inviting opinions opinions are wonderful
and there you have to deal with them
when you go pitch your story and you go
out into the marketplace but you should
you should wait until your bubble of
yunus of your authenticity is so strong
that other people's opinions bounce off
your bubble and you can hang on to this
world and allow people to be to see
because it's transparent and you can see
the world outside but nothing touches
you and if you can live in this world
where you are fully yourself creating
all kinds of fantastic things from the
land that gives you joy and people can
criticize you and tell you you suck tell
you you'll never succeed and you float
around like I have no idea what you're
talking about you won and then the
greatest thing is when you start
crossing things off your list right
rather you're like wow I didn't know
where that for example I I wanted to you
know I wanted to go to Russia
I didn't no idea how I was gonna get to
Russia and darn I just came back from
Russia you know so it things manifest
like you you don't even know where
they're coming from but so we were
talking about writer's block what I've
learned about this this bubble cuz I
believe so strongly in it is that so
much of writer's block and so much of
incomplete
incomplete projects come from the
inability to deal with other people's
opinions I am NOT a big fan of writers
groups where you're giving opinions on
all on everyone's projects yet the the
ability to hang on to your own to your
own identity and the belief in the power
of your own identity is so much more the
path to success the path to getting
everything you want when you start
asking for too many for other people's
reflections on your work and start
asking for validation or Direction don't
go back inward inward find your core
find your strength if the time for
feedback is when you feel so good about
your project and you you will be able to
discern
the good feedback from the bad feedback
you'll be able to hear oh this purse is
just talking about their own work that
this they're reacting to their to
something that's triggered them or
they're trying to give me their purse
their personal opinion because they they
feel strongly about something that I've
written but it doesn't work for my story
right there's there's a power that when
you come into the marketplace and you're
ready for feedback that you're able to
say that's good feedback oh that makes
my story better oh I can see how that's
a great twist or or even I may not agree
with them but I can see how their
opinion would make my story different
and I might go there
so it's this centeredness that you want
to go out in the marketplace with and
until you have that centeredness you're
going to be whipped around like a like a
like a you know like again that hamster
in a little hamster wheel trying to
chase people's approval and it's you you
can't succeed that way and it'll it'll
demoralize you so we often hear someone
say hey I just finished a second draft
something can I send it to you for your
review or even a short film do you
recommend people do that because at some
point we need to see it some from
another set of eyes because our own are
very biased to what we do we all need
feedback we end and a Peter my partner
of many years has always given me great
feedback but the difference is how you
stand within the feedback so if you're
if the desire for feedback comes from
wanting someone to fix what you have or
wanting someone to approve of you or
wanting someone to to validate that
you're talented or validate that you're
gonna succeed or validate that you have
a good idea
you're asking for trouble it's so much
more valuable if you can imagine that
what you write and what you create is
like a child and in its wholeness
it has unity and strength and value in
the world now in the same way you would
not look at a toddler and deem it that
it's going to you will never make money
in banking sit down go back to the you
know go back to where you came from I
never do that you have to appreciate
that that child the city is gonna learn
things and you're gonna want to to teach
it Spanish or you're gonna want to to
have it develop its talents but you have
to approach it as if as if it has value
in itself if if you start rearranging
the elements of the story in this in a
way that destroys the wholeness of the
child you've just birthed you're gonna
be frustrated and go back to square one
I've just seen so many writers because
we both teach storytelling really be
willing to rearrange anything because
somebody with authority has told them to
and even though that person with
authority may be very smart they may be
a studio executive they may be a
brilliant story coach they may be a
producer
you're still the guide of this child
that you've created and if you don't
know your own work and your own path for
this and believe in it as it is you're
you could end up in development hell for
another five years trying to please
someone who
doesn't really know what they want
because they're chasing the marketplace
they're not really interested in the
integrity of your work so it's a balance
it's a balance but it it absolutely
comes first and foremost with with the
strong core of knowing how good you are
how unique your voices and the the
ability to to hold your Center let's say
you have a bubble around you and you
know who you are and then the bubble
gets popped yeah for whatever reason oh
it will oh okay it will it'll get popped
oh yeah oh yeah yeah bubbles get popped
because and it comes from disappointment
right most often you you are this close
to your most perfect imagine deal was a
book or is with a producer and you're
and you can taste it and you're already
buying your house in Malibu you're so
excited because all of your dreams have
come through it's on your list and then
something falls apart and that's the
moment where every story that you've
ever told yourself or anyone's ever told
you about how you're not going to
succeed comes ringing and it's this
echoing voice that's that you're afraid
that you're manifesting and proof again
the universe hates me that is going to
happen that is going to happen it's it's
recognizing that obstacles are not our
external and there's a difference
between what happens to you in the world
and your willingness to believe in
yourself over the external and
it's it's not you know I'm not somebody
who believes in like karma well you you
know you you somehow deserve this or you
needed this right but I do believe that
the stronger that core is that allows
you to know who you are and know what
value you bring to the world the easier
it is to overcome that the shorter time
your disappointment gets the key is how
you frame the story this is the most
important thing how you frame the story
of your disappointments so if you truly
believe as I do that it's the story is
never over until that the ending is
happy so when that bubble is burst I've
just hit the end of the third act it's
the moment where the the hero's lost
everything the worst thing that could
possibly happen has happened and I know
the next thing that happens the next
scene is the hero pulls themselves
together and figures out how to overcome
it and so it's always my choice is this
story gonna gonna end sooner or later
and the sooner I pull myself together
and go to go have the showdown with the
villain which is internally and myself
my own self-doubt
the sooner I know this story's gonna end
happily do you have some rituals you do
to kind of like okay I get 24 hours to
grieve or I get 48 hours or a week and
then now back on up I need something
that's probably really counterintuitive
which is that I know that every negative
story that I'm telling myself holds it
longer so the faster I can first tell
myself this is a negative story I'm
telling myself right that's the first
thing I say the story that the reason
that I'm crying is because I'm telling
myself a really crappy story and at the
moment I'm believing it and that sucks
too
I really wish I could stop believing
this crappy story
three I'm not there yet but soon I'll
stop believing this crappy story for
well it's not as crappy as it was
yesterday
so I must be getting better but I still
hate this crappy story so it's just this
progression of distancing myself from
the crappy story the crappy story is not
me
it's not truth it's not reality and as
storytellers we all know how powerful
stories are and the most powerful story
is the story I'm telling myself and as
soon as I realize that this is just a
story I'm telling myself and if I just
told myself the story that oh my gosh I
just ended the third act I'm so close to
the end and the happy ending then I
would get excited and I would get over
that crappy story sooner and sooner I
can get to that the better it goes so
I'm I'm not a big believer in I'm a
believer in the the shortest amount of
wallowing as possible and if I can't get
there at least I can say at least I know
this is a story and not real the reason
you tell stories is so that we can learn
to be the hero of our own lives then any
obstacle that you face you decide what
part of the story we're in yet you know
we are you in the same way that you
write what your characters are going to
do and how your characters are going to
react you can do that for yourself you
can you can have a really crappy meeting
with a studio executive and you can
either choose to say see I wasn't meant
to do this or oh this is the moment
where the hero decides they're gonna
learn how to pitch and they have a goal
and they they go off and find friends
and mentors and but know very well
there'll be more twists and turns coming
but that's part of the fun of the
journey so it's kind of like it's
appreciating this too
the story would be no fun if there
weren't twists and turns it's so much
more fun to get your goal if it looked
like you never were gonna get it the joy
is so much sweeter on the other side of
that and so if you have a really huge
disappointment you should just know that
when you do win it's gonna feel so good
story maker what what is that story
maker was born out of the land of
blocked writers and it's a 90-minute
process that gives you prompts basically
to to develop a character-driven story
based on anything you could take pickles
airplanes hotel and because we've live
in stories we watch stories we're so
immersed in storytelling it's in our DNA
and if you can stop thinking and just
allow your reaction to go forward you
will develop a story I'm not saying
it'll be a great story but it'll be a
story and it'll have a beginning middle
end and it'll have characters who change
and dilemmas that'll be interesting and
a genre that you're that could attract
an audience but these simple props when
you when you start just allowing your
first reaction to to come forward you'll
start to feel how powerful your internal
storytelling clock is and I have more
much more confidence in it and so that's
the that's the reason that I came up
with this process because the other
thing is as writers we practice dialogue
we practice scenes right we practice all
these things but no one practices the
art of telling an entire story so if I
can get you in ninety minutes to tell an
entire story beginning middle and end
good or bad we don't know but beginning
middle and end in
many minutes you could do that once a
week which means you could have 52
stories at the end of the year and how
many good stories do you think you'd
have if you had 52 stories every year
probably more than you have now and you
would also be building an incredible
muscle of developing ideas of being able
to solve story problems of knowing how
characters change of knowing your genres
about knowing your ups and downs of the
rhythm of a story and it would just
become part of you and you wouldn't even
have to think about it and so that's my
goal for writers to really learn this as
a dance like you would learn the tango
and learn to dance this story without
even thinking for the last year what
have you been up to for the last year I
took off a year from writing from
teaching writing and I've been focusing
on my own writing but and the other
thing I've been doing is living this
list do be in half a hundred things a
doobie and have what I've learned is
when you relax please let me rephrase
this I spent a lot of my life wanting
something that came very slowly wanting
to be the successful writer wanting to
be a successful teacher wanting things
and the process of wanting is actually a
very constrained emotion it limits
things right if you think about the the
abundance of the universe and this huge
funnel of amazingness and then wanting
makes it very narrow it actually makes
things come much much slower and so last
year I decided that I would stop wanting
I would just allow whatever to happen to
happen but I was gonna kind of clear my
slate and so I cleared my slate of
teaching and cleared my slate so that I
could just both live and see what
happened like what if I stopped wanting
to be a writer what if I stopped wanting
to be a teacher
what would
but right and so I did this experiment
and a couple things happened on my list
of a hundred things to do be and have
those things just started coming really
quickly so last year I've had the most
remarkable year of travel concerts and
crazy things and I've also relaxed into
knowing that there is great timing and
they cut my confidence for both the
ideas that I have and their development
has softened into this sense of knowing
that I'm on the right path at the right
time and that I don't have to muscle it
for it to occur and in and so it's
almost like I've taken a huge exhale and
all of my muscles have just softened and
I am getting much it's much easier to
write it's much easier to be happy as I
write it's much easier to believe that
what I write is going to land in the
perfect place and and I don't have that
tug of wanting and not getting so from
that place
I just have this great sense of wanting
to teach people things that I've learned
and to have people to be able to give
other people the gift of exploding their
writing there's the other thing about
being a teacher sometimes is that you
spend a lot of time nurturing other
people but when you don't when your well
is not full then it's much harder to
give what they need right and I've had
this year of really filling my well
and experiencing life and getting so
many things on my list of do bein have
that now I feel like I can I can give
people so much more energy and so much
more attention and so much more insight
into how to be creative and how to
manifest their dreams and how to
manifest the life that they want because
I feel like I'm I've done that I've done
some great things and I can show you how
to do that too there must have been
quite scary those because I get the
sense that you meant I mean everybody in
LA is driven it seems like they wouldn't
stay in the city sometimes probably they
wouldn't be so so set on accomplishing
certain things but it sounds like that's
a very scary thing to do if you're
driven driven and and want things and
and to just let it go and and walk away
from that for a little bit how was that
uh it is it is I do think I do think we
have to be willing at that it's
important to figure out why you want
something and if you're wanting
something because your father told you
you were you were meant to do it or not
meant to do it
right you're doing a tour out of a sense
of I'm gonna show you right and it goes
back to that idea of knowing who you are
and appreciating that the people who are
really great writers live and if you're
stuck in a world of struggle you're not
living and you don't remember who you
are because you've defined your life as
struggle and trust me that's not who you
are your life is so much bigger and so
for me it was getting out of this
Hollywood Los Angeles I've got to look
I've got to drive this car and live this
place and look at how my life look a
particular way to be valued and instead
say what if I were just happy what would
that look like forget being the
successful super a list writer what
would happy look like and so I chased
happy and in chasing happy I feel like I
can do anything and that's just so much
more fun than struggling you're now
entering back into writing it's story
Expo 2015 so you're are you able to take
more of like you said this this sort of
like this relaxing this deep breath
because you have kind of crossed those
things off on that list and and what's
that like to kind of come back
it's almost feels like you're entering
the mainstream again or something I'm
entering the mainstream but I'm also
entering the mainstream with this larger
knowledge of how diverse the marketplace
is I just met with a Sony executive from
Russia who's just sold selling things to
Turkey I'm talking to people who have
who need content on every level and so I
have a really deep appreciation of how
much content is needed in the world how
many stories are needed in the world and
from this place of being kind of full of
my own happy I'm very confident that
both my stories will find a home and the
people that I work with have stories
that will find a home and once you take
out that the sense of struggle and you
begin seeing how expansive this
marketplace is how expansive the need
for content is and how much really the
whole world is calling for you then and
I and I feel like I can share that with
the people that I work with to really
give them
very strong sense that they can relax
because their work is needed and wanted
in the world and and I know this and I
know this because I have I've relaxed
enough to see it there's a book called I
think meditations for women who do too
much and Wilson chief I think and it's
it's about that whole being driven and
and and it's funny because what boss
that I had actually gave it to me and it
was her book and so how do you relax
into that when you maybe start to see
your your haunches getting up when it's
like oh I see that and I want that I
want that then you're like wait a minute
wait a minute I'm gonna come back to the
place of just maybe not wanting are
there other things to bring you back
well first you have to know that your
wanting is just the sign that the
universe wants to give it to you
straight up so you can relax you can
want it it's kind of like knowing that
you you you you're wanting Christmas to
come well christmas is coming you don't
have to do anything to get it right so
that wanting is the sign that it's
coming now you may not know how it's
coming and that's where the hamster
wheel comes in because we think we have
to do it all ourselves and that's why I
suggest the list of do being half
because I'm telling you the list of do
being have generates it and I the other
thing that I do very strongly is this
letter a letter to the universe and I
just came back from Burning Man and that
was my project because four years ago I
wrote a letter to the universe and I
promise you every single thing on that
letter came true and the the technique
is basically being able to feel what's
coming without needing to know how it's
coming so if for example you want an
amazing writing career
why do you want that white writing
career well I want to be famous I want
to mmm like what's the experience of
your day-to-day life that feels so good
to you being a writer and if you can get
to that if you can say if I said okay
well I want to be able to get up in the
morning and have my cup of tea and not
have a day job it's just me and writing
and I have a beautiful desk and what am
I looking at well I have a window with a
garden and I can see what time is it in
the morning oh it's it's 7:00 in the
morning okay so you're starting your day
at 7:00 and so if I can get somebody or
if I can if I can get somebody to talk
about what they love about the idea of
being a full-time writer and feel it
feel the tea in your hands feel the
sense of fingers on that on the keyboard
feel what it feels like they'll allow
the ideas to come feel at the end of the
day how much you've written feel what it
feels like what do you do do you work
until 2:00 do you work so really feel
the day if I can and feel okay so then
what happens so I want to feel what it
feels like to be in a bookstore and see
somebody picking up my book I want to
feel what it feels like to stand in
front of people and read right and the
more you anchor into the why the
experience the sense of of being in this
future life and then begin to see
yourself as realizing that that life is
true it's coming and that's why you can
feel it then you just have to follow you
follow your instincts and it will come
it will come and you'll be amazed it
will come so for that woman who's who's
getting sucked into how do I get there
and do I need to network and maybe I
should go to that meeting I would say
spend more time feeling what your future
life looks like and the impulses that
come to you the ideas that come to you
will lead you to where you want to go we
all the path for everyone is very
different and the more connected you are
to knowing what you want your life to
look like the more will come there's a
very simple simple metaphor in mountain
biking just true in life where you look
is where you go in mountain biking when
you're on a single track if you look up
you go up I don't care how small that
track is you keep looking up the bike
will stay on that road this wide but if
you look down you will go down so the
more you look at I don't have what I
want I don't know how to get there I
don't know what I'm doing I don't know
if I need to talk to that person the
more you'll get that the more you say I
know something's gonna guide me there I
know my ideas are good I know they're
getting better I know my path will work
I'm just going to be patient for it the
more that you'll get that so look up
look up look up and relax it's it's
knowing that when you look up the whole
energy of your body and the connection
to the earth keeps you on a straight
path it's the physical and it's also how
you manifest what you want in life